okay guys so welcome back to the screen
welcome to video number 32 one of the most
important
videos of the entire ptm video series why
because we're now going to look at
catalysts and what you
have to remember all the time guys
throughout this video and in the future is
that catalysts are the
difference between what constitutes an
investment idea and what constitutes a
trade idea so although
we are only dedicating one video in the
entire video series towards identifying
catalysts and
the discipline of being able to actually
identify catalysts in your trade idea
generation process
it is absolutely crucial to what
distinguishes the difference between an
investment idea and an actual
trade idea and therefore on top of that
the difference between what classifies you
as a trader
and what classifies somebody else as an
investor now before we get into the
processing skills of how
you actually go about identifying
catalysts we're going to need to set the
stage here and we're going
to have to get all of the background
information in place so you fully
understand how catalysts actually
fit in to the bigger picture and
additionally you're going to have to learn
what actually constitutes a catalyst
there's a big difference between what a
catalyst actually is and meaningless
information that isn't actually going
to move a stock and a lot of that comes
down to discretion and experience so here
on the screen now we have our familiar
pro trader systematic process for long
short portfolio management within the 20
to 60 day time horizon
but we do need further clarification at
this stage as to how catalysts stock
catalysts actually fit in to the entire
process so we have our two major stages of
theory our
our groundwork our research and then we
have our actual implementation when we're
going into the market with real money to
take a position
so in theory in our work that we're doing
to identify potential long and short
ideas we have our quantitative process
which is split up into macro and micro and
micro
and we have our qualitative process which
we have our qualitative process which
we've just started to go through in the
last couple of videos
so through our quantitative process
we are fully focused and this is 80
information
idea generation
then we actually have to think is down to
technical analysis and price action
indicators which we will be coming on to
later in the video series but at this
stage when you're from the funnel which
the trade is actually a green light as
long as there are catalysts in place
without catalysts what we essentially have
is an investment idea so if everything
stacks up fundamentally and we've
identified a positive or negative
outlier and we actually want to take a
fundamental position in this stock so
either a long or a short position what we
essentially have at this stage is an
investment idea not a trade idea
when we do our fundamental work yes we can
have our best practices when it comes to
volatility market cap
filters etc. We are going to be located in
areas of the market with our long ideas
and our short ideas that are fundamentally
driven
We're going to be located in the market
which suits our time horizon
However, if we have no foreseeable
catalysts within our 20 to 60 day time
horizon
then we are relying on unknown factors to
get a return within the time horizon
So we need to go through with every trade
idea our fundamental processes to identify
positive and negative outliers
to identify positive and negative outliers
and then we must identify catalysts
that are going to drive the stock within
the 20 to 60 day time horizon in the
direction that we forecast
This is what's going to get the stock
moving within the time horizon
and the discipline that we must engage in
on repeat over many trades over a long
period of time
because that is what's going to get us our
outsized absolute returns
and yes visually when you look at the
process here boxed out as theory and
implementation
so our research and then our real money
real world implementation
when you look at this in sequence we have
fundamentals then timing and then trade
structure and risk management
However, what is the point in attempting
to time a trade with technicals and price
action indicators
if we actually can't identify any
catalysts that will drive the stock within
our 20 to 60 day time horizon
Well, the answer is simple. There is no
point in doing that work. It will be
wasted time and energy
So for sake of work efficiency and
optimization
We jump from fundamentals to catalyst
identification
Then we look at timing and trade structure
afterwards
So this is why identification of catalysts
is so crucial to our overall trade idea
generation process
You must never ever forget that a trade
idea is not complete
until you've actually identified catalysts
and then done further work on timing and
trade structure
So never forget that a trade idea is not
an investment idea
nor is it actually a day trade
Remember, we sit in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon
We are utilizing fundamentals in order to
generate a bias
So a directional bias whether that's long
or short
in identifying positive and negative
outliers
What we're essentially doing is we are
identifying stocks long or short
that we have a directional bias in
However, at the fundamental stage
we haven't placed a time limit on our
trades
We've just engaged in some best practices
where we've had market cap filters
and we are leaning towards areas of the
market
where we know we get the volatility
Of course, that's going to increase our
chances
versus not doing that
But what's going to increase our chances
way more in getting outsized absolute
returns
within the 20 to 60 day time horizon
is identification of catalysts within our
time horizon
So we're placing a time limit on our
trades
We are operating in the 20 to 60 day time
horizon
and by identification of catalysts
we are turning a fundamental bias
an investment idea into a trade idea
So let's have a full rundown of the whole
process here
and what it really means in detail
So what actually is a trade idea?
Let's define it
So we're using in our process
the best disciplines of investing
but we are also using the best disciplines
of trading
So if you recall back to the entire first
part of the PTM video series
What were we trying to achieve there?
We were trying to achieve a portfolio bias
What is this discipline?
It's a discipline engaged in by both
traders and investors
It is fundamental identification of the
macroeconomic tailwind
Where are we actually located across all
asset classes?
Well, we are located in the stock market
We focus on equities
because that's where the most volatility
is
and where we can get outsized returns
consistently
by both traders and investors
What is the type of volatility
that we want to expose ourselves to as
traders?
Well, ideally what we're looking for is
around 20% annualized portfolio volatility
or slightly greater
which means we are looking at 1.5 times to
2 times the level of the long term average
of the volatility index
The S&P 500 volatility index
The VIX
And we also want low correlation in the
portfolio
And this discipline is not necessarily an
investor discipline
unless you're located in corners of the
market
like being a small cap only investor
It is much more a discipline or a practice
engaged in by traders
Now, what is our strategy as traders to
exploit this volatility?
Well, we are long short portfolio managers
within a 20 to 60 day time horizon
Investors are long only
Therefore, this by default is a trading
discipline
Next up, fundamentals
So, the identification of stocks
utilizing fundamental supporting evidence
that's both forward looking and backwards
looking
to enable somebody to take a position with
real money
And that someone is utilizing both
quantitative and qualitative processes
This is a practice that is engaged in
primarily by investors
Why?
Because if we just look at fundamentals
with no time horizon limit
This is an investment practice
So, yes, as traders, portfolio managers,
long short portfolio managers
We do engage in the fundamental processes
to identify potential investment ideas
But what separates us as traders versus
investors
Is that we have a shorter time horizon
We must have catalysts that occur within
the 20 to 60 day time horizon
So, the positions that we take are
actually defined as trades
Not investments
And they don't turn into investments in
our trading account
With no time horizon limit on them
So, for our next two steps
To turn what we would define as an
investment idea
That is a potential trade idea
Turning that into a trade idea
We must identify catalysts within our 20
to 60 day time horizon
That will enable us to gauge entry and
exit prices
And therefore a return
So, that would be our timing on the actual
trade
And it will actually lead us in our going
to be long or short stock position
Or an options position for optimizing
return on investment
Consequently, whether you take a long or
short stock position
Or actually replicate a long or short
stock position
Utilizing option structures
This, by default, is preventative risk
management
Which brings us on to our next stage as
traders
Our risk management processes
So our PRM, preventative risk management,
self-imposed rules
And our reactive risk management processes
Where we act on winners or losers
We have live positions
But as traders
The way we set our preventative risk
management
And our reactive risk management
Is very different to investors
And then when we actually exit positions
We have hard coded data
That we refer to as trader statistics
And this is very different
In the way that traders measure their
performance
Versus investors
What we're actually doing
Is measuring the effectiveness of a trader
Which is different to measuring the
effectiveness of an investor
Now, don't worry about the risk management
and trader stats parts
For the moment
As in the details
We're going to be looking at that later in
the video series
At this stage
It's just very, very important
And this is the message
We're trying to
This stays in
To the overall process
Generating a trade idea
Does not mean
Stopping
At the fundamental stage
And conveniently
Choosing to ignore
What our time horizon
Actually is
So when you look at this list of steps
And how they are defined
In terms of whether
It is a utilized step
A utilized process
By either traders or investors
Just simply look at the line
Where we have fundamentals
Fundamentals
So the fifth line down
The fundamentals
And the fundamental processes
That are primarily used by investors
But also utilized by traders
And then look below it
You'll see catalysts
Which feed timing and structuring
And you'll see risk management and trader
statistics
And in each descriptor
You'll see that timing, structuring, risk
management
And trader stats
This is what separates traders from
investors
And also where we place ourselves in the
market
For consistent opportunities
Within the time horizon
That optimizes those opportunities
So that would be specifically
Our volatility
The volatility that we choose to expose
ourselves to
And the strategy to get the most out of
that volatility
On a risk adjusted basis
So the processes that we engage in
As traders
That distinguish us from investors
Is volatility
Strategy
Timing
Structuring
Which are driven by catalysts
Risk management
And trader statistics
One of the worst traps
You can fall into
As a retail trader
Is by engaging in practices
That lead you to becoming an investor
And not an actual trader
So whatever we do
We mustn't let our long short trading
process
Become an investor process
And we must never ever let
A trade that we are exposed to
A trade that we're putting on
Become an investment
And we must never ever let
To make a trade that we're going to
Thank you.